Speaker 1: Just a reminder that if you want to
get on your nickname should be name and location
or location and name some combination of
that. For example, Evan from Las Vegas.
Evan from Las Vegas. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Thanks for taking my call. I
had a question. Just I feel like when Trump first
kind of rose to power in 2015, it felt like it was
going to be like a crazy moment in history that
we would look back on it, kind of laugh. And now
that's really become the base of the Republican
Party, this misinformation and kind of willful
ignorance. Do you see that like changing or like,
how will we look back on this time in history?
Speaker 1: Listen, the question of how will
we look back on this time in history is one
of those that you ask 100 people, you'll get
100 different answers. Nobody has any clue
imagining how the future will retrospectively.
I could give you some gas, but I really have no
idea. My hope is my hope is that Maga Trumpism
will die with Trump. And by that I don't mean
Trump's literal death necessarily, but the death
of Trump's political career. Because the truth is,
if Trump doesn't get the nomination next year, and
certainly if Trump loses the election next year,
I think it's completely over for Trump. That
will be the end of Trump. And then we will have
to see what happens to MAGA Trumpism. Does it
get rejected by the Republican Party? Does it
take over the Republican Party or does it get
integrated into the Republican Party? Sort of
like the way Tea Party ideology was integrated. My
hope is that MAGA Trumpism dies with the death of
Trump's political career, be it in 20, in November
of 24 or in January of 29, when the next president
would be inaugurated, and that at that point we
get back to something being a marginally more
sane Republican Party, and that history will
look at it as an aberration. That's my hope. I
don't know that that's the way it's going to go.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I definitely, definitely share
that hope. I had one other brief question. I
heard you mention recently that you're going
to be in Santa Cruz, California, which is my
alma mater. Can I ask what you're up to there?
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. I'm going out
there for a wedding. And it's the
Santa Cruz area. It's not it's not actually
Santa Cruz, but it's the Santa Cruz area.
Speaker 3: Oh, okay. I see. I wasn't sure if
you were maybe doing a speaking engagement
at the university or something like that.
Speaker 1: No, no, no. But so what's the is
downtown Santa Cruz worth checking out? I was
doing some street view sort of, but it's it's
sort of unclear to me what's going on down there.
Speaker 3: Yeah. You know, I haven't been. I've
been like, in the last probably a year or
two, and I love it. It's just kind of like
a chill beach town, you know, there's
some some cool record stores, you know,
breweries. And if you want to get a bagel,
there's this place called the bagel that
has pretty good bagel. Lox. I know you're a fan.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. And is is the salmon cold,
cold, smoked, do you know?
Speaker 3: You know, I don't
I don't know that, but.
Speaker 1: I'll see if
I can make a call up. Find out?
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah. You know,
I'm a I'm a Jewish ethnicity, so I like to think
I have decent standards for for my. Know the locks
and I think it's decent.
Speaker 1: Are you for
scallions or chives in cream cheese?
Speaker 3: I could go either way. I guess
if I had to pick, I'd probably go.
Speaker 1: Oh, dear God. Okay. All
right. I'm going to let you go.
Speaker 3: All right. Oh, now.
Speaker 1: I'm Scallion all.
Speaker 3: The way. All
right. All right. Thank you for your call.
Speaker 1: Think you know I'll report back about
Santa Cruz. Cool. All right. Take care. There
we go, folks. Big time. Big time stuff. Let's
take a very quick break. Don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones in a moment.